[Música]
saludo hablando de la salud del planeta
vamos a hablar de nuestra salud vamos a
empezar entonces marc con el anuncio de
by un tequila farmacéutica está
empezando a desarrollar nuevas vacunas
sobre qué sobre cohetes y nos dedicamos
para combatir a 19 u otras buenos dias
raúl si es para combatir el coi 19
también está desarrollando otras
tecnologías pero nos vamos a centrar en
esta porque también hablando de
soluciones como decía marina podría ser
una de las claves tecnológicas a ponerle
fin a esta pandemia de covite nueva que
ya llevamos tanto tiempo viviendo con
ella es una presentación que hizo
valiente que recordemos que son los que
han desarrollado una de las vacunas
junto con fighter más usadas para luchar
contra el cubit 19 y hablando de
proyectos futuros en esta presentación
que hizo bayón tec estaban hablando de
dos tipos de vacunas nuevas que van a
empezar en ensayos clínicos en la
segunda mitad del año 2022 que de hecho
pues técnicamente empieza mañana por un
lado unas vacunas para reforzar las
células t recordemos que son esas
células de nuestro sistema inmune que
tienen memoria esas vacunas de entonces
pues no harían que no nos contagiará mos
de kobe 19 pero harían que nuestro
cuerpo estuviera mucho más preparado
para luchar contra el por otro lado unas
vacunas llamadas pan coronavirus en
general que podrían proteger o contra
todos tipos de coronavirus o contra
varias variantes del sars co2 que
recordemos del virus del hobbit 19
además de su variante fue pues quien
puso la tecnología de a rené mensajero
en estas en esta distribución de las
vacunas país él fue quien pues puso toda
la capacidad de distribución y de
producción así que nos podemos esperar
que sigan investigando en esta línea
cómo se harían entonces marc estas
vacunas de pan coronavirus pues
empecemos diciendo que este término es
un poco confuso no porque hay algunos
que lo usan para referirse a varios
coronavirus acá ya hay otros coronavirus
que provocan por ejemplo resfriados
comunes y hay otros que se refieren a
las variantes del como 19 nos vamos a
centrar precisamente en esas posibles y
potenciales nuevas vacunas pues a prueba
de variantes digámoslo así hay varias
que están en fase clínica aquí en esta
recopilación que hizo el estudio una la
revista han hecho los tenemos y que
además se aproximan a eso pues con
varias tecnologías algunas con a rn
mensajeros que es lo que podemos esperar
quizás también de baión tec que buscan
eso dar esa señales genéticas a través
de la rn del virus del cob y 19 para que
el sistema inmune lo reconozca y esté
preparado para luchar contra ello cuál
es el desafío encontrar esos que son
genéricos que no son particulares de
distintas variantes de distintas
mutaciones para que den esa protección
más amplia sin embargo hay otros por
ejemplo que usan otro tipo de
tecnologías algunas llamadas rbd
research vending domain se llaman que
hace eso pues esa es una parte pequeña
de la espiga que representaría como la
llave que encaja perfectamente en la
cerradura de las células para infectar
las lo que hacen es usar estos rm de
distintos coronavirus de distintas
variantes para dar una protección amplia
hay algunos que son escépticos al pulsar
llevamos años intentando encontrar estas
vacunas tan amplias contra la gripe
sigue sin funcionar pero bueno sabemos
que contra el coronavirus hay mucha
inversión también hay mucha prisa quizás
eso ayude en este caso y pues es
cuestión de tiempo no algún día pues sí
seguramente lo vamos a lograr y
tendremos otros retos por delante pero
vamos hoy a empezar una sección de
respuestas a las preguntas de nuestros
televidentes nuestra audiencia a mari le
pregunto que tenemos hoy hoy tenemos
pregunta que viene desde youtube como
veníamos diciendo estamos intentando
pues responder las inquietudes de
alrededor de la salud que tienen a
nuestros televidentes sigue intentar
suplir una consulta médica por supuesto
cualquier pregunta personal sobre salud
vayan a los profesionales que les pueden
responder pero hoy nos preguntaban sobre
enfermedades de los ojos particularmente
no cómo nos puede afectar el celular si
ver mucho celular puede afectar nuestra
salud y la salud de nuestros ojos la
respuesta amplia es que sí pero no solo
a nuestros ojos sino en general vamos a
empezar desgranando esa información
primero la luz del celular también la de
las televisiones también tabletas
ordenador dones la del estudio de hecho
en horas de la noche
recordemos que nos pueden interrumpir
los que se llaman ritmos circadianos que
es como el cerebro identifica si es de
día si es de noche si tiene que estar
activo o tiene que descansar es a corto
plazo pues interrumpirlos puede provocar
irritabilidad fatiga problemas de
insomnio entonces pues se aconseja no
ver nuestros celulares cuando estamos a
punto de ir a dormir por otro lado
también se sabe que tener la vista
fijada en un punto muy cercano como
podría ser el celular todo el rato pero
también libros computadores
hace que tengamos problemas de vista con
el tiempo que se puedan desarrollar con
el tiempo entonces esa también es una
recomendación y de hecho también si se
ha encontrado que particularmente dañino
es en niños niños de cortas edades ver
mucho celular o tabletas ordenadores en
algunos estudios que se hicieron por
ejemplo en shanghai en suecia norberg o
no y sin embargo también queremos
explicar que estas limitaciones cuáles
son las limitaciones de este estudio
como siempre nos comprometemos a una
información rigurosa y tenemos que decir
por ejemplo que ese estudio no tenía en
cuenta otros factores de uso de vida
diaria de uso de otros como decíamos no
sólo celulares libros cómo se estudia
cómo se trabaja que también pueden
influir mucho en la salud de los ojos
entonces pues tener en cuenta sus
limitaciones y finalmente el tema de la
grana luz azul que se ha dicho que es
tan dañino en 2018 será un estudio bien
alarmante que decía que podía acelerar
la ceguera seamos claros el estudio
demuestra efectivamente que la luz azul
puede dañar nuestra retina puede dañar
nuestros ojos y puede acelerar este daño
hacer que veamos borroso con el tiempo
sin embargo no demuestra que eso se
pueda achacar
de los celulares era un estudio en un
laboratorio no era un estudio en la vida
real por lo tanto toca tomarlo con mucha
precaución no es que sea mala idea
intentar evitar pues con filtros esa luz
azul pero tampoco es que nos vayamos a
volver ciegos con el uso intensivo y
como lo decimos marc también pues esto
es una información generalizada ya pues
cada quien que vaya al especialista
obviamente su médico de cabecera el
especialista en este caso de los ojos
para las recomendaciones individuales
ahora le pregunto qué recomendaciones
tenemos para mantener una salud general
de nuestros ojos así es raúl pues vamos
a explicar que además de los celulares
hay muchísimas otras cosas que también
influyen y que pueden influir tanto o
más de hecho que el uso de los
smartphones para empezar por ejemplo
incluso una dieta saludable tener una
dieta balanceada bien nutrida nos puede
ayudar a prevenir problemas de visión
con la edad por otra parte fumar también
incrementa el riesgo de cataratas por lo
tanto siempre dejar de fumar por muchos
motivos es una buena idea pero en éste
también gafas de sol para proteger de
rayos ultravioletas en momentos de alta
intensidad de hecho el sol también emite
esta luz azul también la tiene entre
otras que nos puede dañar los ojos y por
último la regla se conoce como regla 20
2020 que escapara por 20 minutos de
estar con la visión centrada en un punto
cercano como un ordenador un libro tomar
20 segundos de descanso mirando a 20
metros de distancia así se descansa en
los ojos y pues evitamos esos problemas
y nada terminar recordando que con la
almohadilla sanlu tf-24 estaremos
respondiendo y a comer mucha zanahoria
para tomar muchísimas gracias como
siempre por toda la información pasamos
a saludar